ich hätte nicht gedacht dass ich diesen
satz man sagen würde aber der wendler
hat mich zu einem video inspiriert 2020
ich habe mitbekommen dass es michael
wendler die dsds-jury verlassen hat um
in den telegramm untergrund abzusteigen
mit der begründung telegramm ist die
einzige möglichkeit hin zu frei
meinungen auszutauschen
alle anderen portale wie die instagram
youtube oder facebook sind zensiert und
wichtige informationen die unbedingt
begreifen müsst werden gelöscht und das
spannende ist wenn ich das glauben würde
dann wäre der fall denner für mich eine
bestätigung in meinem glauben denn er
verlässt ja nicht der dsds rtl hat sich
von ihm distanziert kaufland hat am
selben tag noch ein werbeclip
hochgeladen wieder runter genommen und
sich dann distanziert und sein manager
sitzt am selben abend bei pocher den
tränen nahe
weil er so schockiert ist der vibe ist
jedenfalls wir haben ihn verloren wer
sich öffentlich als verschwörungs
ideologe outet verliert seine karriere
und sozialen anschluss ist das
eigentlich in ordnung
ernst gemeinte frage lasst uns darüber
mal so unaufgeregt möglich diskutieren
deswegen wodurch ein team macht es euch
gemütlich wir steigen durch was versteht
man eigentlich unter zensur die
definition von zensur ist die kontrolle
von informationen durch verbot
unterdrückung in der regel aber nicht
immer ausgeübt durch den staat mit dem
ziel politische religiöse oder
sittlichen normen vorzuschreiben welche
arten der zensor sind recht alltäglich
wie zum beispiel das zensieren von
kraftausdrücken wie krisen oder
wo ist doch die meisten denken bei dem
wort zensur wahrscheinlich ein
staatliche zensur zum beispiel wie in
china wo facebook google youtube und
vieles mehr gesperrt sind in deutschland
spricht dagegen artikel 5 unseres
grundgesetzes jeder das recht seine
meinung in wort schrift und bild frei zu
äußern und zu verbreiten und sich aus
allgemein zugänglichen quellen
ungehindert zu unterrichten aber nur
weil meinungsfreiheit ein grundrecht ist
ist meinungsfreiheit nicht grenzenlos
bleiben wir bei unseren gesetzen da gibt
es zum beispiel das strafgesetz über
volksverhetzung und wer zb den holocaust
leugnet macht sich wegen volksverhetzung
strafbar
hinzu kommt dass der
nationalsozialistische völkermord
stattgefunden hat wird die verbreitung
erwiesen unwahrer und bewusst falscher
tatsachenbehauptungen nicht zur
meinungsbildung beitragen kann und als
solche dann auch nicht von der
meinungsfreiheit gedeckt ist dass man
als kleiner reminder für zwischendurch
fakten sind keine meinung aber vor allem
steht keines unserer grundrechte über
allen anderen
deine freiheit seine faust zu schwingen
endet da wo meine nase anfängt also auch
grundrechte können schranken oder
grenzen haben wenn man die rechte
anderer oder eben andere gesetze
verletzt und genau diese grenzen sind
auch explizit im gesetzestext
niedergeschrieben wer also grenzenlose
meinungsfreiheit fordert kann sich
zumindest nicht auf unsere verfassung
beziehen zb kann auch das recht auf
versammlungsfreiheit grenzen haben wenn
zum beispiel bei einer großdemo durch
missachtung der schutzmaßnahmen das
infektionsrisiko das recht auf
körperliche unversehrtheit verletzt
das heißt einzelne rechte können nicht
beliebig über alle anderen gestellt
werden sondern da muss man im
zweifelsfall von fall zu fall
entscheiden
und das wird auch gemacht beispiel hier
wurde jemand wegen holocaust leugne und
volksverhetzung angeklagt konnte aber
erfolgreich verfassungsklage einreichen
da das bundesverfassungsgericht zu dem
schluss kam dass hier der holocaust
nicht geleugnet sondern nur verharmlost
wurde
und das fiel dann unter meinungsfreiheit
solche fälle zeigen was für einen hohen
stellenwert meinungsfreiheit hat und wer
corona leugnet macht sich übrigens auch
nicht strafbar
nun sind ja die gesetzlichen grenzen
nicht die einzigen grenzen der
meinungsfreiheit michael wendler
behauptet auf instagram youtube oder
facebook werden wichtige informationen
die man begreifen muss
ok schauen uns das mal annehmen wie
youtube hier werden ja durchaus
bestimmte inhalte gelöscht zum beispiel
pornografische obwohl es legalen zugriff
auf pornografie gibt verstöße hiergegen
die youtube community richtlinien
verstoßen corona kritische oder
regierungskritische inhalte gegen diese
richtlinien nein zumindest gibt es hier
keine kategorie die dazu passen würde
außerdem gibt es ja etliche auch
reichweitenstarke videos die die
maßnahmen der bundesregierung sehr
kritisch betrachten oder die pandemie
sogar ganz in frage stellen und
offensichtlich nicht gelöscht sind aber
zusätzlich zu dem gesetz und den youtube
richtlinien kann ja jeder kanal noch mal
seine eigenen regeln aufstellt zum
beispiel haben wir ja die kontrolle über
unsere kommentarspalte und wir kriegen
erstaunlich viele kommentare die
behaupten gehörten kommentare löschen
was seltsam ist denn in wirklichkeit
lassen wir so gut wie nie kommentare
kritik ist wichtig und persönliche
beleidigung stören mich nicht weil ich
finde dass die eher negativ auf die
kommentierenden zurückfallen also mich
schauen wir uns doch mal diese
angebliche zensur in unseren kommentaren
an erstmal ihr findet ihr etliche
kritische bis beleidigende kommentare
unter unseren videos die sind schon mal
offensichtlich nichts gelöscht aber
vielleicht kommen wir einfach nicht
hinterher mit dem löschen vielleicht sie
nur deswegen auch kritische kommentare
übrig naja aber wir würden uns ja das
raushalten unbeliebter meinungen durch
blocken erleichtern also das ist sowieso
für mich die einzig sinnvolle
vorgehensweise also wenn ich einen
kommentar schon so inakzeptabel findet
dass ich gehen löschen möchte dann will
ich auch den ganzen user überhaupt nicht
meiner kommentarspalte haben und wie ihr
seht haben wir gerade mal zwölf user
geblockt und diesen kanal gibt es seit
2016 und neben dem blog 0 gibt es auch
eine liste mit speer wörtern ich könnte
ihr zum beispiel schimpfwörter eintragen
oder auch wörter wie löschen und dann
filtert youtube angeblich auch ähnliche
wörter wie gelöscht raus und alle
kommentare die sperr wörter enthalten
werden dann vor der veröffentlichung
zurückgehalten es sei denn ich gebe sie
manuell frei aber diese liste ist beim 1
wie ihr seht woher kommt also der
vorwurf dass wir kommentare löschen
vielleicht schreiben dass man ja einfach
um ins zensur vorzuwerfen
oder es liegt hier hier seht ihr die
tabs überprüfung ausstehend und
wahrscheinlich spam wo kommentare von
youtube zurückgehalten werden
und obwohl die tatsächlich sehr viel
spam und rheine beleidigungen dabei sind
gibt es auch viele kommentare die zwar
kritisch sind aber völlig in ordnung und
gehen keine gartens verstoßen sogar
positive oder sehr hilfreiche kommentare
wie man dieser liste landet ist mir
selbst nicht ganz klar also vielleicht
werden andere user kommentare oft melden
oder werden kommentare links enthalten
können sie als bm eingestuft werden und
selbst wenn wir alles genehmigen wollten
man kann nicht alles auf einmal
freigegeben sondern nur so 10 20 30
kommentare auf einmal und da kommen wir
einfach nicht hinterher ich fand es
wichtig dass man zu zeigen weil
einhaltung von richtlinien auf social
media plattform in aller regel von
algorithmen kontrolliert werden und
algorithmen können fehlerhaft sein und
algorithmen sorgen ja eh schon dafür
dass sich fronten verhärten ja weil
algorithmen mir immer inhalte
vorschlagen die sowieso meiner meinung
entsprechen also wir verlieren kontakt
und damit auch verständnis für andere
meinungen
und wir sind immer in unserer babbel und
wenn ich dann die wahl dann doch mal
verlassen und irgendwo in kritischen
kommentare lassen und dann wird er nicht
angezeigt weil youtube das als
potenziell unangemessene flat obwohl der
kommentar an sich völlig in ordnung ist
dann verhärtet dass front natürlich noch
mehr und das ist sehr schade wert been
set nur weil ich keine kommentare
löschen heißt das nicht dass ich finde
dass andere creator das genauso machen
sollten es gibt gute gründe kommentare
zu löschen und ich weiß wir lesen dass
auch dass manche unsere zuschauer sich
das wünschen würden dass wir das mehr
machen weil sie sich ein forum hier
wünschen wo man sachlich über
wissenschaft diskutieren kann und leute
die spam oder beleidigen stören da halt
einfach oder nur weil ich mich nicht
störe an persönlichen beleidigungen
lesen das ja auch andere leute und wenn
die was rassistische oder sexistische
lesen müssen
fühlen sie sich vielleicht selbst unwohl
oder unsicher ich bin also nicht dass
ich ihn richtig oder falsch gibt ich
weiß auch gar nicht ob wir jetzt die
beste lösung haben es sollte klar sein
nur weil meinungsfreiheit ein grundrecht
ist habe ich ja kein grundrecht
irgendjemandem ungefragt das feedback zu
geben zum beispiel ein christlicher
youtube-kanal atheistische kommentare
gelöscht dann finde ich das natürlich
nicht gut aber dadurch ist ja nicht
meine meinungsfreiheit verletzt ich kann
ja meine atheistische meinung anderswo
und das ist ja keine staatliche zensur
deswegen muss man zum fall wendler ganz
klar sagen wenn er behauptet dass er nur
auf die idee kam frei reden kann dann
liegt es nur an telegramms community
geil 1 oder den den fehlenden guidelines
und hat nichts mit unserer verfassung zu
tun also sein grundrecht auf
meinungsfreiheit ist nicht verletzt
gleichzeitig wird sehr deutlich dass er
einen großen preis zahlt für seine
meinungsfreiheit
seine karriere ist in ihr wird
öffentlich verspottet ist es denn
wirklich meinungsfreiheit wenn man dabei
so viel verlieren kann ja also nur weil
ich ein recht auf meine meinung habe
habe ich kein recht darauf dass diese
meinung einfach so hingenommen oder
gefeiert wird gleichzeitig kann ich
verstehen warum man sich so fühlt als
könnte man nicht mehr alles sagen und
ich glaube dass gerade dieses social
media algorithmen und diese echo kammern
sehr viel schuld daran tragen dass wir
heute immer seltener respektvoll und
offen diskutieren und immer häufiger
überhitzt und verbittert und dieses
klima fördert radikalisierung und ohne
witze wie weiß ich ob sich ähnlich geht
aber wenn ich als mutter darüber
nachdenke was wir sorgen ich mir über
die zukunft meines kindes machen dann
ist das neben klimawandel und
artensterben eine sehr große sorge
darüber was das internet aus unseren
sozialen interaktion macht es wird auf
jeden fall helfen meinungen und
tatsachen klarer zu trennen
und während wir auf diesem kanal dafür
stehen dass tatsachen verdrehungen nicht
akzeptiert werden dürfen
ich stehe ich genauso dafür dass
meinungen solange sie nicht
verfassungswidrig sind
mehr akzeptiert werden sollten zu
akzeptieren ist vielleicht
missverständlich ich mache ich jetzt
meine meinung einfach annehmen soll
sondern dass man offen ist und versucht
zu verstehen ohne dass man sich einig
werden muss was meint ihr zu diesem
thema was sind eure meinungen und
kriegen wir es hin hier respektvoll
miteinander zu diskutieren also
zumindest auf diesem kanal bin ich
tatsächlich ganz optimistisch denn das
muss man auch mal sagen die freunde der
sonne sind in dieser hinsicht schon
verdammt gut und dafür auch danke vom
ganzen team hier der link ich euch ein
video von die da oben über reichs bürger
die ihr unsere verfassung tatsächlich
nicht akzeptieren und eine wahre aber
unglaubliche geschichte über eine masern
leutner werte schaut doch mal vorbei
ansonsten sehen wir uns in zwei wochen
und bis dahin bleibt sicher ihr reasons
it